every every second we wait here you're
dying
hi I know we check Oh God I you're
protecting the lane right now I'll
switch the gameplay Jesus I like
normally we would do like try to recount
what happened last week do you want to
you know where we are so you kind of
jumped in we'll just ask you are you
doing this because you think um are you
testing me because this story is dry I'm
just curious because it's kind of
chaotic okay not try to make funny we
were in know you were if I was try to
make fun of you you would not i dick i
do know when it happens uh I was gonna
say was we were in a train sequence and
I kept getting hit by the train a lot
I don't remember interacting with any
characters and then the train derailed
and we're in this graveyard that's all I
remember I don't really like was their
story not really not that I they're
[ __ ] creepy like this guy is super
creepy cool no no perfect they're gross
and they're like you're injured by the
way because I saw it we were like
setting up he was like setting up the
audio and he kept getting attacked with
his shovel guys and I was trying I kept
trying to please they're disgusting you
know they kind of remind me Oh gross
just the way they walk it kind of
reminds me of attack on Titan yeah you
know when they like they walk like
babies oh you guys ever see Mike McCarty
an event ask him to do the baby walk oh
it's hablar walk those are very
different things because I have a baby
walk do you know but the toddler off is
I had not done in a while and I forgot
about it it's so funny it's no don't ask
me in an event do it oh [ __ ] wait did
you fall in a hole yeah there's gonna be
a guy down here oh I'll try to help you
there's there's a metaphor here fighting
in don't fall
oh so cool your grades right there boy
wants to bring it not gonna do sorry I
killed her hey watch this watch this
yeah I'm trying to jump into the grave
terrifying all right come here how do we
run again holdbacks
right I'm back so gross no more comments
[ __ ] I fell in again so stressful
we just played this game and it wasn't
nearly this stressful I know more
comments in the last episode said we
should play Jake's campaign but maybe
that's cuz I didn't ask
Jake Decker right or whatever his last
name is supposed to be before you find
out it's Jake Western sorry some blue
put your mic in front of your mouth it
is like okay it might I do something
but it all is that better oh god yeah
this mic has been [ __ ] though lately
sorry that sounds better right a little
better yeah definitely better okay Mike
right in my mouth
there are so many things about this that
I do like it's pretty genuinely scary Oh
gross
let me get out oh my god I made a
mistake I'm a mistake I fell into one of
those dumb graves again I was trying to
be cool I'm an idiot
I have to make let's go
no I really need heal oh yeah come VIN I
saw people in the comments we're still
here
some people are still confused how the
herbs works oh yeah you like combine
them to make them work it multiplies
them Oh dogs gross huh I thought he did
a tuck and roll but he just died yep
he's dead um it's raining it's pouring
that's me
dogs cats [ __ ] bird
I see I don't know if you saw but Sundy
area twitch got a clip that was like the
biggest clip of all time and it's a guy
getting scared playing outlast - he gets
genuinely afraid because his his like
toddler daughter is in the room and she
like scares him on accident yeah he like
freaks out so that like inspired me to
go through like all these clips of
people getting scared and so that's
that's what I did I like went through
all these clips
yeah and found a bunch of people who
like scream and stuff and it's so funny
I think people getting freaked out is
like the best clip I startle pretty
easily me too what a regular dog kind of
harken guys are worse things than
chasing a dog surly raspberry yeah it
could be chasing us
oh she's good oh [ __ ] wait where is it I
went back down to where we started
and go back down there okay if you were
to attract a dog how would you do it
I would I would have cheese in my pocket
put peanut butter on my ding-dong sorry
yeah meat in my pocket and those are
both the same thing I think our dogs
attracted to cheese I don't I think
you're mixing up your animals well I
don't think they're attracted to your
dick yeah it's the peanut butter are we
supposed to kill him or chase him I'm
confused
change him then kill him got it I think
I killed him oh that was a different dog
I guess oh I found an emblem it's back
here behind that
shovel where are you dog I see I see you
[ __ ] I see you see it we train Jupe Jupe
oh I died I got you
Sammy know where it's gonna be alright
they on Sam Kennedy I'm in a lot of
trouble here no you're not
check yourself before I wreck yourself
that doesn't sound good thank you
hey drop the key summit this is your
voice you should blame yourself
ooh damn were in a tight spot I really
like this whole treasure trove of Tic
Tacs to get back to healthier with all
the sudden Elena just became like a
Vietnam vet let's cut looked at two
tours ice that's just a character from
Tropic Thunder Jack like really good
I should be kicking more I feel like I
don't kick enough
I've heard there were zombies in Vietnam
I think you're thinking of that movie
with the zombies and the Nazis but that
was a different war and there were Nazis
I've got a key it's like that graveyard
and resonable three actually I don't you
suppress that game or not open I
what's the graveyard and resume the
three sorry the park nevermind you go to
a park later on
well good time
Wow I'm coming oh wait are we separated
yeah well nothing broken anyway good
thing too that's that my ego in [ __ ]
cool Bob's back I'm so cool wait where
are we going we're separating I don't
know yeah all right
no Eddie get up it of kids I know like
it that's some [ __ ] it gave me the
prompt
give me the prompt with prompt yeah
[ __ ] everyone's gonna know well what
does this guy what is this guy what does
he say this why is he running away from
me there's a where's auntie with a huge
neck that's running in the opposite
direction you that is so gross I'm
having the same problem you are he ran
from me so I don't have a lot of ammo
shaggy screaming
Oh sick if you're sprinting and then tap
L and hold it you can aim like yeah
shoot them in the Mecca thing I'm
freaking out I I'm actually like a
little scared here I don't like them I
need help Oh am i close to you now I
don't know I'm gonna die
no yet not coming I'm Dave I think I was
getting close to I'm dying
wait I'm coming I'm sorry I like panic
look I'm like genuinely afraid right now
I'm not that far from you oh it's my bad
I like I got really sick I got I got
really scared or something I don't know
the whole situation was really scary all
right I'm back I'm back just keep moving
forward if possible so we can meet up I
like ran out of ammo and just like
everything went bad I got a shotgun now
I'm okay what is your problem
that's some [ __ ] happening what me
I'm just getting absolutely destroyed
while these [ __ ] this one guy
actually looks like a [ __ ] the one
with the neck I killed him before
screaming this serious problem here so I
need like an emblem to go on this door
sad maybe it's something I find good oh
he's got a vest on too bad he didn't
wrap his head in it what he shot you in
the face
yeah what if he shot me in the face
don't you run from me
I hate that guy hey hey he's gonna
scream oh he did so do you have my
emblem or are we still looking for that
I don't know if I did that right
jeez that was ter not actually like come
back out this way the first time in a
while that I've been genuinely scared oh
that's cool
yeah bring it downstairs right and then
press l may be near shotgun out Thanks
now press and hold L while you're
sprinting and keep holding ax l yeah aim
how I did L - yeah I bet you if you
press I bet you if you do that into
someone yeah that's a good sign that's
why he's still alive
just so you do it I'll tell you what I'm
not playing well but I'm having a great
time yeah I still genuinely believe that
this game is just a fun romp lake so
it's not a great game like I'm not gonna
fight for it but in terms of
entertainment I'm having such a better
time than I did with re5 yeah which just
felt like such a slog most of the time
like it's kind of scary yeah it's more
the tension comes out of oh my god just
straight-up lied to that guy I haven't
sinned O's so today
he'll be like flames well that guy's got
a bus that's stupid
Oh better face yeah that's happen to me
another in send oh and then send Oh
classic I heard Walmart gave back all
the two orders for incentive oh my god
all I all I saw today where people like
freaking out about it
crying about it like you do know that
old [ __ ] a lot of bad stuff happened
today in this country I won't go into
today was the proverbial bowl and a
political china shop any better what a
dick he was oh that didn't work that
didn't work thank you
watch out move Bach oh yeah helios out
got him
no I didn't get him
whoa cuz that just did a really weird
thing I saw that you said it was just
you it is you sired my friends yeah
today was a bad day wasn't it in general
yeah we use that another ensign no I
hope you like hell
look I jumped oh that didn't do anything
I didn't do anything all oh yeah he's
pretty strong I would shoot him with
bullets
not this fists I got a slug with your
name on how long is this gonna go on
how long must we endure this sorry
he threw a dynamite at my head
I threw that way too far cool wait you
should be dead [ __ ] I'm not doing some
good [ __ ] wait so are we allowed to get
in more I guess so yeah we good okay god
damn you sorry
are you dead I love it I'm like just
punch my food alright can we get in yeah
I'm trying
I do you need help do you need
assistance do you want to go inside or
what circle quick okay take balk I got
it I got hit with some acid okay you
know what
run run run good call yeah presser on
the door okay sure that guy's pain like
I said we're not doing great but I'm
very entertained
I look like a vampire yep are you rescue
workers it's not gonna be the
appropriate time but time your shirt
there's my number you know probably time
but can I wear your skin you're dirty
how did she know that what did I miss
you want to tell me what's down there oh
yeah she was leading let me be Elena
with the belly button you be Leon and
just look at my belly button that's all
you
oh there's barrels and bonus skill
points left me Father if I've sinned
it's been 24 years since my last
confession
oh wait I can open mister you know that
take a penny leave a penny
I always owed me tick but I never leave
remember those stories in the papers
about those kids who all disappeared
mm-hmm I killed all of them sounds a bit
worse but the pennies though that's
what's on my conscience
accidentally ready to do but driver for
style-conscious but I never did anything
to fix it cool secrets nothing in it
it's a cool looking Church this area is
very resonable for like that graveyard
and key in the chapel stairs under this
statute
it was open the last time I was here all
right whatever crazy lady there's a
Madonna fàbregas over here oh I just
have to put it on this one no oh a
ladder that doesn't look stable that
does not look stable I want to help you
I have a Madonna of happiness lady
Madonna what's it like up there there's
another Madonna pedestal
I put happening well we need another
motherly Saint yeah dumb dumb I'll go
find her who's the other one that was
Mary
well that's Madonna Oh Mary's the other
one what was your name Mary Magdalene
yes actually that's what I was talking
about Catholic upbringing a founder
Madonna of charity and Madonna damn it I
don't know if I'm allowed okay well I'll
come up oh we might have to do this
simultaneously anyway somehow we boat
yeah you need to go the other one where
is this ladder you drop for me neither
down the aisle to the left oh I almost
killed that man he's shotgun with me oh
there was a sophomore Nicole yeah my way
the BSAA
you watch he'll be here with the whole
army any minute now
your son he did I hate to be the one to
tell you this but he like super date did
you already like totally investigate
this whole area well we don't share loot
so yeah there
what hold on
I love rain like really like rain sorry
[Music]
you don't hear it no I hear it I like
rain - we don't get enough here it just
made me laugh sometimes in the winter we
do like a I you I listen no like rain
white noise stuff to fall asleep
sometimes cuz I'm sure everybody wanted
to know that Leon oh he felt asleep to
the sound of fear what am i doing press
upon it
oh it's like let's go perfectly what the
pedestal that red thing yeah no yeah
yeah yeah got it
oh I got it I'm gonna throw up
where'd you get that oh my god
this isn't really a puzzle let's go I've
had enough of this game girl
this game has just begun here's gonna
have to let that [ __ ] go oh I just
booted you that's not according to me is
that you know that was pretty seamless
though cuz I'm still playing
I'm Q by me again friend might be sure
that's the first time that's happened
touch pad and then no oh no I might have
to restart it from the last checkpoint
just get oh I just got one too this is
the first time this has happened
just uh cuz like get the next checkpoint
and then oh okay let me just go solo
alright we yell at me and tell me how to
do it oh then what are you doing here
defeat the statues yep what wait wait
let's talk about it God that was I
defeated it scary Elena to switch on
these statues that shuts ah yeah that's
faster than I would have done it
jeez I didn't even do mine on purpose I
just like haphazardly foe oh no Lily's
doors oh this is good it looks stupid
alright we do it okay okay alright so
end game session right hammer and
screwdriver and wrenches there's no
hammer there these are like in games try
joining
can I invite you outside of the game
[Music]
give me a second
yeah explore the menus for a little bit
okay this one looks like a map or graph
this one looks like Pentagon web this
one is a you you turn signal pin cushion
oh that's cool and realized that that
was a wrench anise flathead Phillips
head screwdriver and the Apple icon
we have been through the menus my name
is not on there I have to back out all
right I'm gonna do it
Oh make me nervous dry wonder what
causes that to happen
come on you bastard okay and bite you
nobody look you didn't even check my
name oh I didn't know they've already
seen my name nobody look now they know
my player icons of watermelon but I hope
you didn't lose anything that can be
always be so draining to like have to
redo stuff people have already seen
sugar ones I know I got the rose I don't
like the sweet ones I like the regular
ones I'm still gonna eat them
we skip this [ __ ] alright let's just
race through those right to be honest
with you we didn't lose that much I
don't even care about that Luke just
throw me out there okay isn't it over
here stairs under this don't you open
the last time I was here [ __ ] what do we
do we'll figure something out get up
there honey go to the ladder you got it
out of my way dumbass my son Marco he's
in the PSA no he's not watch you'll be
here with the whole army any minute now
this was with PSA got both hey you go to
that one got it
I think ah I think Chris is still in the
BSAA and this one if memory serves all
right cool nothing must be missing
something there must be three of them it
couldn't be more obvious you have to do
this at the same time or what I just do
it Zeus is such a dick curse you
merciful Poseidon when I asked what was
going on and you were like oh it's too
easier to show you that like felt like
such a Resident Evil 5 thing to happen
because the Resident Evil 5 everything
we did was like God was like what do we
do in this situation and they were like
would you like to know you'll find out
soon enough and it's just like just tell
me just tell me yeah like I'm there I
was gonna get a little bit dicey there
we go
you lost the place craps he said days
Oh God Oh God there's a bunch of it's
like whack-a-mole except with crossbows
and your own body such a weird very
preventive measure too because it's like
Oh exactly
wait did we do it no god I'm in a lot of
troubles like the Guardians from the
breath of the wild lasers no one scared
me
I got it mm-hmm I'm gonna watch you you
got it
well there's gonna be more I think yours
is a me and me really oh [ __ ] that
should have hit me god this is dumb so
dumb statues are so cool-looking no
they're not one these remind me of the
doors Hamas is a lion these would look
like the doors from the Shadow Temple in
of ocarina of time when you walk through
them this won't hurt me right oh I hope
not because I almost just ran it check
it milk it doesn't hurt who is this oh
it's a gun laser that's what it is
a gazer what am I supposed to do come
over here you old geezer I don't know oh
do we have to aim our gun lasers into oh
yeah cool so dumb
we had very different reactions to that
lady oh let the rain fall down and wake
my
[Music]
well Wow
how do you know that it's the Beatles
classic classic Beatles oh wait can you
laser that dish at the same time i laser
my dish
sure all right let me know when you're
done oh you have to do it from the other
side do you have another side yeah wait
that's the one I'm oh oh no no no
everyone do you two do mine
hi
[ __ ] off
I'm in no mood for you right now I
should save those I'm up to your little
down bottom left left yeah got it
oh the fab Madonna
hi Leon hi I'm Melina and I'm mad wow
he's got a gun semi-auto it must be
semi-automatic
oh it's automatic fudging beautiful we
mean I don't know it's just just look at
it rain
shut up hold on a second
am I supposed to do that - yeah you
already did two of them nice guest third
one you got it sister
there is no fourth one I don't think
what is it is there there's no bail on
that fourth one cracks
what does that mean toll the five bells
clear I'm reading this the true path
shall appear what a dumb ass oh wait I
want to the final one ring all five
bells I'm stuck on this stupid thing
one two three four there must be like a
secret tiny one so you got shy up face
Bell you got the one on the chicken
yeah weight-wise yeah
ah found it oh yeah I wanted it you
could see it it's on the other side I
thought I'll do it fine that's all and
feel bad [ __ ] antiques like they asked
for it
[Music]
it's like you saw the cameraman come
he's got [ __ ] look cool Hey
got it yeah
did you hear that sounded like it could
have been Dom be was a door come on this
way there we go
no [ __ ] fatofi fall I've been watching
glow on Netflix oh it's so good I'm like
six episodes in yeah I think I'm about
the same Elena
[ __ ] sorry how many statues do we have
on us collective for but I don't see one
yeah glows super good Alison breeze
really good
that's the main one right yeah main
actress yeah she's great that person's
all wet and stuff we got buttholes on
their body
well obviously get away from there it's
infecting everyone around it
Oh time to why didn't we just stay up
there and shooting you it's so gross Oh
shouldn't you be in second
oh [ __ ] I'm done thank you
I got some hairspray what I am son do is
a clown that's a good call you he's
[ __ ] really gross [ __ ] so hard to
change weapons efficiently I just always
feel like I just wanna kill these people
they're like no we got this
we have all that army training [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] at this game so many my not allowed
to even be close to him no now what he
does I'm coming I'm not doing great
Leon embarrassed
oh [ __ ] that's a zombie okay
we have to do something people are dying
well they're [ __ ] me they're like
dunzo [ __ ] he's gross
are we supposed to save these people
yeah I don't know understand the thing
god he's disgusting just a real charmer
you should probably have a different gun
oh [ __ ] but probably not so Marshall run
up to this thing but hey um
oh [ __ ] do you need help yeah
he's so disgusting [ __ ] I'm not good at
this game get up there ya [ __ ] oh my
god these regular zombies why do they
have to grab me on fire
get away from him look they're just
standing there
I'm [ __ ] in a lot of trouble I'm
getting we're supposed to do something
when it's done
there we go what a vile little Oh who's
got keycard fine just disgusting little
creature so did all those people die
most of them we didn't save any of them
basically not hey I don't see anybody
alive Here I am oh it's one thing I
don't have much of where is some I don't
know
great I was hoping you would know no I
found I'm getting a lot of points here
all right oh I see an emblem oh crap I
don't have a gun to shoot it
I'm coming it's up back where we came
from I need where we jumped down from
none of you could have dropped ammo
we're like in the store no the balcony
be originally I was right here up there
on the stained glass on the coop saying
oh I see it good eye I'm sure we're
gonna get ammo really soon there's a
fire grenade thing over here
that's nice
I wish I believed God were looking out
for us right now doc I think we're on
our own
dad's taking it he's getting sick of
watching over us I think this panel and
the numbers on the doors are connected
that oh my god what was that sorry
[ __ ] comes out of nowhere okay I can't
do that no good it's not gonna budge we
have to go in here
I didn't see anything in there
am I supposed to know and the numbers on
the door that's 12 this is something
zero I'm not sure what else just keep
doing me neither
oh okay yeah so does this open it I
guess I'll just do uh what start with a
zero one two uh-huh no no like Oh got it
all right I'm back yeah
one two all right listen I got it this
time
doctor I've got a medical emergency your
head is blown off take two and call me
in the morning I'm opening up the next
one I need to know the number though is
it all messed up or something try one
zero two okay one one zero two one of
those screamy dudes no yeah he's dead
nope no he's not
hate those guys there's a surprise all
right I'll try to zero one okay to zero
one and that one there nothing and two
one zero eight over this
got it
so I'm so proud of myself
ah one of these guys again no hold on oh
my everything
oh he's not he's dead a couple more to
do for now you okay
nope airman he did fifth grader could
bust out of here wants them to punch in
the numbers and the doors
1:02 okay actually hold on a second do
two one zero I think that'll close this
door behind us which would have to be
helpful in case other games come okay
they're only opens them right now one
zero two
all right here we go screaming he's not
that don't go in there screaming he did
Oh is there plant there's a plant how
come I can't take it is it cuz I have
all this [ __ ] waste you know what I'm
dumb
[Music]
alright from now on I'm just gonna throw
a random grenade got 1 2 0 okay
what's in there
okay killer dead guy waste all right you
two zero one do that there's zombies in
there wait which one was that
was it back here great another puzzle to
solve
I'm like way past you dude oh that was
through here okay try zero one two not I
should both be open
great where was that first one used -
okay Oh back here sweet okay he's kind
of people are commenting on the oxygen
tank last episode saying like it would
take a lot to blow it up like it did
oh really like this game is trying to be
realistic I don't think but alright I
made the promise and I'm gonna keep it
[Music]
sweet sweet wait what promise I'm going
to throw a grenade so that I can take
that cuz they I don't need all this [ __ ]
can I use this remote bomb like should I
put the remote bomb somewhere that work
it's likely gonna have a zombie or no I
think I want zero to one just feels so
bad throwing this [ __ ] away
alright I don't think so triangle
there's like no give button I guess can
I combine it like what I have a super
grenade the unused tape two good days
ago I'm so smart all right I'll just get
this stupid things and dumb so
disappointed in myself
zero to one
[Music]
I think it's zero water to one yeah it's
open let's go Nia calculator next time
oh there's a Bob interrogating zombies
why do you want to eat me wait I
remember this place must be so this
charity flea market I bought it for her
lapdogs who are you why did the chair
Jack her memory she just crouch down
stared at at point-blank please be okay
he day he's so dead wait I went the
wrong Levitt emeral around my neck
she's strong it appears to be some
secret lab it's the last thing I
expected in the resume
well she doesn't look great he was
always milk everywhere wait so is that
person like day yeah
here's to be wise are only a curtain on
one side in case they come in from this
IO there's air blowing it we must be
heading toward the outside there's a guy
right there hold on I see you don't even
don't even try it
me he day I say you he did oh did you
get hurt
no you just tripped over him well she's
alive who are we looking for
is it some kind of like ethereal he was
pooping I got it
get some stuff in here you missed it
no I saw do you see it I took his um
oxygen tank and I hit him with a very
cool oh you can just drop things oh can
I not do that get on my wife please
thanks Dee well I mean it was boarded
throwing I guess there's a bunch of
cells I opened on the way here
did you okay
he's like investigating something right
here
look the water rotates clockwise we're
in Australia that true I don't think so
well I found a little secret how yeah
the right stick what yeah it's on my
right stick I think I got a knife and
you got a shock on the starters I've
been trying to use it more my final the
finishing moves with a knife are really
enjoyable we're getting kind of tired
you're stringing me along are you gonna
fill me in here
[Applause]
bear with me a little longer I didn't
yeah I just thought it would give me
your scalp on [ __ ]
[ __ ]
killed him when I have the chance me and
my knifing am i right I just won't look
at myself in the mirror often I'm
through pretty cute I mean oh God
tears like tyrants in here what okay the
door wait didn't go the wrong way
no go through there are circle over here
nope oh it's like when you fought Wesker
in the first game I do remember this oh
[ __ ] this is gonna be a thing isn't it
this looks all too familiar
hmm what the hell is all this
none of these were here three days ago
you must have been here three years ago
a happy birthday happy birthday
it's a crock
beautiful wait
cloning her at such an uninformative
video what you want to show me no tell
me oh no it's like the end of the
prestige what the hell did I just see
something you know Aida how like the
stories in this intersect
yeah really melodramatic but I guess
kind of cool all right wait okay sorry
okay
oh my guns look at the scene oh my go do
it
no yeah cuz I know what's gonna happen
why is this locked no point in going
back anyway
what no I just don't know
is there a panel here somewhere that I'm
not seeing oh here we go what was number
201 yeah were you doing that in hip next
to these tyrants things let's go our
security system is stupid
hi do you think up in life yeah
dogs why
and we're here is beneath us
oh yeah oh you little idiot he's stupid
oh that work
the electricity or something I get it
activate the one by one everything have
to be complicated
this entire area that's what I'm so
tired game this entire game doesn't like
what kind of areas
oh [ __ ] they're coming out of the
rafters it's not even a public speaking
let's run back and forth
oh no I just separated us oh [ __ ]
oh no I'm in trouble
no it happened it happened right as that
thing happened
whoops sorry what the hell did I just
see god damn it um 201 let's go I want
to kill that dog before it comes up
again because I missed he outsmarted me
like dogs but not rabbit once skip this
Henry no fine
I get it you have to break them one by
one so you're gonna have to come yeah so
you gonna have to come here and press
the one the other side all right how
about you do it sorry if you want me to
stay here you'll need to go there come
over here but press this next lever like
I did last time at all
give me that wine you're getting oh did
I just bottle that dude I did is the
press that lever I pay on the side i
bottled that guy
like the the finale moves are really fun
we're like what are we doing I think I'm
supposed to be on the other end or
something am I supposed to go down here
good job
come on Elena
you gotta activate this thing oh there's
a guy shot him I'm coming watch out
crawl
I forgot to press L&R at the same exact
time you do like a quick-fire shot
that's cool
oh [ __ ] I'm understand stamina oh you're
injured
there's a guy yeah
oh it's letting me what a circle yeah hi
anyway am I supposed to get in there I
don't know what's going on up there
nothing go back to your room is it Dom
B's now you tell me if it's all these
okay no so wait is all this happening to
you but not me
oh it's arm off I have all these cool
finishing news there you go you can come
over now I think Oh servant or an aide
those suckas
well alright oh that's on my side anyway
I did it
hey [ __ ] bottled me
yeah respect your elders
I'm not old dear you okay your songs
though where are we going over here okay
he tried to bottle you oh my god there's
water let's hope for zombie shard whoa
there
thank you
oh my god just shot in this so done yeah
I shot him - [ __ ] they're dropping from
the ceiling
die you know I want to kick that guy oh
that's [ __ ]
maybe I know how zombies work Leon this
is your first zombie right I got this
come over here press circle okay behind
you right next you have to make a run
for it come on
I'll go see you girl
six hours into the zombies
stop it I hate mouth sounds there must
be in some sort of cave with rafters
what time is it
Deborah Deborah done our job look like
Deborah
what's that from song I do know that's
from oh it's from baby driver but it's a
song no I know but I'm like that yeah
we're not hear it last
emblem and I burned through some ammo on
that last round look do you want answers
you should be prepared to give a couple
yourself yeah and your face like half
the time I think what bothers me about
this is that the secrets that they're
holding it's not like it's you know a an
offensive thing or anything it should be
a secret yeah it's like it's like she
kept it for no reason no it's like she
was like yeah you're right I really
should give you some answers and then
she like she like pretends like she
didn't say anything how about we call it
here before the store or next checkpoint
is this a checkpoint
wait did you know it was her name with
Deborah yes oh I didn't hear that as I
guess really weird the oh i know this
part i remember this the chapter is
called deborah oh oh i think i know this
part for some reason doesn't she become
like a gross monster i'm pretty sure no
I'm pretty sure I think I have to carry
her out and you have to protect us well
there's like a huge dude here but one of
us has to carry her okay I think she
becomes it I'm calling it she's gonna be
like I'm disagreeing I have to keep one
of us gonna have to carry around time
she like explodes into the monster
that's what I think's gonna happen
alright piggyback ride take care of her
hostile you look so good let's go yeah
moving suspiciously fast or someone with
a person on them yeah you're also her
butt is bouncing wait hold on look at my
screen isn't it her dress how the deuce
do you see my screen oh my god I wish
hold on wait maybe I can get some of
that go on down yeah okay no oh yeah
sure then turn around oh my god I don't
know if that's necessary but here we are
I like how you can like pick up plants
and stuff alright I got this this is
ridiculous hi zombie wait wait aren't
zombies bad enough without the machete
so boring there makes I'm just gonna
keep getting as close to danger as
possible at least you can see upper but
there's like something so so blatant
about that when you really can see like
but it really bread but oh god you
should probably let me go first
I hear them what is that got it watch
out watch out Mary I still got my shoes
behind you okay okay I was trying to
save you sorry I [ __ ] up Oh I threw
him off the bridge don't worry this
what's the name of the Power Rangers
when they combine
or the what's the name of the Autobots
and they combine whatever total Megatron
oh go Rangers Megatron that's what I am
right now
Debra gets down [ __ ] around alright
there's a dude down there anything I'm
gonna go first I think it would be
better to throw her over a shoulder you
just want to stop looking at her booty
hole there balloon knots right in the
middle of my screen hey wouldn't it
requires less strength on her part oh
damn it
did I do it enough alright here we go
again oh there's a little secret
get that little secret can you wait oh
[ __ ] you
honestly swear swear quick what do you
mean that's where that's where yes [ __ ]
where are we going right here this way I
don't like not fighting well right let's
dig right here I'm running past him
good job got a machete in his body he's
dead now suppose we ancient corpse
pirates pirate corpses sorry these are
ancient corpse pirates a very special
breed of pirate that are now dead and
also corpses Oh No
maybe that's a good time to end it is
this normal
no this isn't normal just please wait no
sturgeon for partner can't strike
cancelling no don't I don't wanna cancel
try cancelling know what doesn't work
we'll pick here pick up here next
episode two times in one Episode whisky
and a bunch of emblems how does that
make sense I don't know I'm not a
designer
I guess we're good
Debra hold on almost there I think she's
dead she's a big booger now it's okay
it's really vile you're gonna be okay
I'll get you out of there sweetie
no don't touch that oh hello ms wang ah
dah
do all those backflips
we just kill was that my sister the hell
is going on here Deborah [ __ ] hate
those answers it's always the same thing
what was a cucumber Ada Wong these
walkways well are we in the same game
anymore
I honestly don't know she's still good
she's okay if we're not the same game
just play it anyway everything you can
beat it first no run Sam you okay help
me though
how do I help you I don't know but this
one might chef are you dead
No
how we're separated good great
I got wrong with me I might give it no
don't take forever please isn't she she
talks more like sane
it's looking at cigarette I'll explain
later
over it nice wait like it these are the
rules here you go
[Music]
that's a counterweight I'm going down
dude move it you might have to pull in
as well she's very cool
watch out that lady and naked hot and
super attractive wait what do I can I
hurt her before I waste all this ammo on
her is there a lever you can pull so I
come down there she's super nude hard
did I like it down there there trying to
enjoy her
keep in mind guys did I get her all
there CMT okay
yeah shoot that barrel mixer okay I got
it
oh he she smacked me dude honestly don't
oh fudge yeah you're supposed to shoot
the club I'm basing this off of very a
very little yeah you do that's pretty
cool Wow I'm coming Deborah [ __ ] [ __ ] I
had to press that any human leaf oh oh
you are dead shooter sorry I was
changing guns like six times I was like
doing that as fast as humanly possible
wasn't working I couldn't see it
Oh Deborah No
you don't have I just wanted stop trying
to help her she's obviously like a nudey
mutant now my god like a booger eat
misty you can see like all up in her but
really hard to watch put her down
got one good job I have done nothing so
far but I feel really good
she killed her own zombie guy oh buns
it's up there so hard to hit do my best
Oh Lord [ __ ] you Debra run nobody likes
you Debra okay
oh that's out she pulled it out all
right I got it I'll shoot that TNT you
got it she's only got like one little
boobie Talon left no wait she grew more
are they gonna be gold or what
it's like the new destiny to strength
get have a why you can boys I want those
though can I not have these why all
right let's go
well taking far too long there's shotgun
shells think about the viewers Mary I
don't want to see this you can't run you
know your senior sex what that way okay
you know free up space with those six it
little help here if I already have three
in there I know let's face to pick up a
green one to combine with those red ones
it's great right
I just I like items a lot and I don't
like to not get them in fact it pisses
me off
[Music]
what can help me out kill people killing
people
there's a few people on the ranch well
hurry up that's boring I didn't know I
could have more than six pills on me
how's it going on your end
my [ __ ] dead
I think we're waiting on you sorry I
mean I'm just running what to tell you
I've been running what is this section I
never saw any of those movies underrated
class
oh [ __ ] you I [ __ ] like I hit him a
lot this must be the thing
well that's slow it sure is I'll cover
you doesn't something really clear yeah
it looks weird
feels weird to be honest I think hop on
Leon fall hey girls
Oh God one of these things section
remember how good I did of these that
gave me no time what the what was that
there's an accent squared that gave me
no Tom we have shooter that's what make
sense
melaina shut up she's not drunk she's oh
my god take the camera off her man this
game Kennedy I'm letting it get to me
those things are not wings she's gonna
be able to like why is the camera
focused on all this so I guess we got
sure
so that she
I'm working on it
get out of here you dumb weirdo jump
idiot no one likes you Debra this is
long ass boss fight yeah there's like a
a ride in it I'm gonna check out our six
there's nothing to do we're just on a
little ride here it's very weird okay we
got to shoot that tan team done
he's weird was that guy was that guy up
to I don't know we know your oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I forgot about the TMZ okay ADA
are you gonna like oh [ __ ] we gotta get
ready for a quick time
nope there might help out or [ __ ]
nice okay okay
oh I'm not having a good time are we all
dead now
this should really kill me that came out
of her face
came out her face right hold on let me
get married yeah murder you in real life
you don't start shooting this girl and
stop worrying about ammo what's the
point of ammo we're not gonna shoot I
love you wait oh it's fine
no Elena I love her oh my god what she's
not dead yet you need to let her go
before she's that she got a killer and
then get upset about it drop her I hate
not having control over my character
what if she became herself right there
wouldn't that be depressing
I thought we were friends
is it her sister did we discover should
we know this by now it's definitely like
family she's been a real wiener about it
for this
who's him how are you some guy
me look at me okay just keep your eyes
on me me I'm gonna get you out of here
Deborah never look at me
we're gonna get through this guy again
and Tommy Lee Jones from metal plaque
is it dumbest way to reveal is your
sister who could say that
[Music]
I didn't know what else to do you could
have told me so like that's not it's not
something that if she would have told me
I would've been like mens breach the
president security okay that sounds like
Simmons all right long story there's
actually stuffing you know that's so
dumb when you find out in a very
dangerous game and if you don't man
answer that whatever that is that prism
I gotta go take this call a bareback I
did that every time my phone rang up
should I bear back and I grapple hooked
out of the room Simmons there grab hugs
here I'll bareback yeah that's my uber
I'll see you later hey mom have you been
so scream good now it's under Browns why
did I have to add another tier under
bronze figured out because we're that
[ __ ] bronze silver gold a long time ago
I earned a dog tag
my accuracy was really low but I still
got a rank a somehow good job
[Music]
penultimate all right
next on the penultimate episode of
Resident Evil 6 we're gonna do that one
where I shove the guy shoves my face
into the fan just like I see in all the
gameplay clips about this game about the
one we're they it's like a QuickTime
event if you don't do it right your face
goes into a fan I know you can hear me
don't ignore me face in the face how you
die yeah get shoved in the face